Hello.
My Name's Sarah and I'm here to talk to you about octomom baby and how Germans
race or kids for software lives.
Um,
I'm really happy to be here at Google,
but before we start,
I'd like to ask you a few questions.
I know who I'm talking to him.
So first of all,
how many of you are here are parents and it's okay if you're not.
Oh,
a lot good in the right place.
Um,
how many of you have school age kids?
So ages six to 12?
Well,
quite a few.
Uh,
so let me ask you this.
If you have kids aged six to 12,
or you had them older,
think back to that time.
How many of you let them walk places by themselves to their friend's house,
to the park?
I see my allies back there.
Um,
or just school.
So just a couple.
Uh,
as you know,
you're probably your very typical American parents.
The rest of you,
uh,
the dominant style of American parenting today is high on supervision and not
just physical supervision.
And I don't know about you,
but I have this snippy thing back in my hometown called power loop where I can
watch the grades as they come in in real time.
Well,
that's a lot of supervision and we have the best intentions,
right?
We want our kids to be safe,
we want them to succeed,
but we exercise so much control and trying to make those two things happen that
we've actually become more controlling than German parents.
Which sounds like an odd thing to say because when we think of Germans,
what do we think?
Strict people write.
Very exacting people rule following.
I had all of those ideas in my head when I moved to Germany,
but very quickly I learned that what I thought was not exactly correct.
When I first moved to Germany,
my daughter was two and a half and we lived there for six and a half years.
Um,
one of the first things I noticed was how Germans interact or don't interact
with their kids on the playground.
Um,
one story that I tell often because it was so shocking to me was I was at the
playground with my young daughters.
She's still about two or three and another kid,
he was eight or nine and climbed on the outside of a playground structure and it
was really high.
And he's dangling there by one hand and there's good 10 feet below him to the
sand.
And I stand up and go walk to home,
which means,
you know,
attention,
watch out kids,
mom,
you know,
I'm looking at all the other adults at the edge of the park,
drinking coffee,
not worried at all.
By the time I turned back,
the kid drops down,
looks at me like I'm crazy and runs away.
And I thought,
there's something going on here that I don't quite understand.
And I found myself having many of those kinds of experiences in Berlin where I'm
the one,
you know,
an Octoni running up to the kids or thinking I've got to watch them on every
playground.
And I started to think,
why am I still afraid or better yet,
why are the Germans not afraid?
So I'm not going to talk too much about what's wrong with American parenting
because I'm sure we've heard it.
All right.
Some people call it helicopter parenting.
Some people call it over parenting.
I think the most precise term that I've heard this from psychologist Peter Gray
and he calls it protective directive currency and I would add that I think it's
primarily based on a fear.
We're afraid for our can safety,
so we protect and a lot of that protection involves restricting.
You can't walk alone.
You kept play alone,
you can't do anything that's vaguely dangerous.
The direction part comes in our fear for their future success or failure.
So we direct all their academic grades,
we watched the rates really closely,
and if they start to flounder and we get on the kid or we get on the teacher,
we have a meeting with the principal and we make sure they fill out their
academic resume with plenty of extracurricular sports or violin or learning a
language.
And that style of parenting doesn't leave a lot of room for the kids to make
choices or mistakes.
Right.
And taken to its extremes.
Some American parents protect and direct through adolescence and into young
adulthood.
And that doesn't leave a lot of opportunity for the kid to become an independent
adult.
But one place that they don't do this isn't Germany.
Oh I forgot this,
I'm bored of me.
But those of you who are parents who will feel our parents here,
um,
I don't think of raising kids as a side issue.
This is something that,
uh,
is important for all of us.
And it sounds cliche,
but children are literally the future,
right?
When we get older,
they're going to be ones running the economy,
making the decisions,
hopefully founding the next innovative idea that changes our lives.
Right?
And so with them,
bigger perspective than mine and your own personal perspective,
I'd like you to consider these two lists.
So,
which is more important to you for children to learn obedience or self reliance
if you had to choose between the two?
Respect for elders or independence,
being well behaved or being considerate.
Good manners or curiosity.
I'll give you a moment just to think about it.
Well,
some of you may have seen this list before.
It's not mine.
It's a list of that researchers use to determine how authoritarian you are.
So if you chose the first column,
obedience,
respect for elders,
we chose more of those things.
You're more authoritarian and your worldview.
If you chose the second column,
self reliance and dependence,
curiosity,
you're less authoritarian.
Now I'm going to take a wild guess because when I'm here at Google in Seattle,
most of you probably took self-reliance,
independence,
that column.
That's great.
And those are all very American values.
However,
if you pair it in that dominant director protecting style that I just mentioned,
you're actually reinforcing the first column because in order to do that,
you're asking for a lot of obedience from your kids.
A lot of respect for elders and good behavior instead of their own initiative.
So as I said before,
the one place they don't do this,
this first column is Germany.
And while I had that stereotype of Germans as being the strict overbearing
parents,
that's true in the 1940s things have changed a lot in Germany since then.
And in fact World War Two prompted a big reaction against that kind of
parenting.
And really against everything the Nazis stand,
right?
The generation that came after them who are growing up in the 1960s really
rebelled against their parents.
And it was going on here too.
But the Germans really had some things to rebel against,
of course,
including how their parents raised their kids.
So there was even an anti authoritarian movement and some people opened up
daycare centers that had absolutely no rules at all.
And I've seen some videos of those daycare centers and they're pretty wild and
things have come back that up a bit from them.
German parents are much more moderate than that extreme.
However,
you'd be really hard pressed to find many German educators or parents who would
advocate for a strict and controlling way of dealing with kids.
And some evidence to that fact is around 2000 they banned corporal punishment,
which means it is illegal to Spank your child in Germany.
And when you think about it,
that's perhaps the most authoritarian thing you can do to a child is use your
physical power over them to try to force them to do what you want to do.
So while they may be anti authoritarian,
German society is anything but a wild bunch of people just running around in
chaos.
Right?
So how do they do it?
How do they manage to raise kids who are not only independent but responsible?
The good news is that you do less,
not more.
The bad news is that doing less can be really,
really hard.
Uh,
whenever I talked to German parents and say,
you know,
how can you let your kids walk to school or,
or take the subway by themselves?
They say,
you know,
I'm afraid to,
I hate it,
but I have to because if I'm always with them and I'm always hovering over them,
we'll never have a chance to learn independence.
So they don't just throw their kids out there,
give them a subway ticket and say,
find your way or you know,
go find school.
They spent a lot of time preparing their kids to take on each new stuff of
responsibility.
And one example of this is walking to school in first grade.
I walked my daughter to school every day about 900 yards through busy city
streets of Berlin.
There's about 3.5 million people there.
And at the end of first grade they had a little course or teacher dead on
traffic safety and they showed her that Zebo Stripe in outside the school.
What's your like the crosswalks and basically the whole area around the school.
And after that I was supposed to let her try to walk to school on her own.
And I thought,
hmm,
she's seven and I'm American.
We are not doing that.
And so ashamed to admit I walked her every day through most second grade and
punt of third while all her for other friends were walking to school by
themselves.
And one day she finally said to me,
you know,
mom,
I can do this.
And I said,
well,
you know the traffic and you know,
there's the CD guys who hang out in the quarter and the afternoon and I don't
like that.
And she said,
mom,
all my friends do it and they're fine now.
I hate the all my friends thing.
However,
she did have a point while I was walking my daughter to school every day.
Her best friend was biking from much further away and she everyday she would
cross a really busy street frankfurter la and she still does as I know,
and she has not yet been hit by a car.
So there is some evidence there.
And then I did eventually let my daughter go and walk to school and when I did
it was transformative,
not just for her but for me,
for her.
All of a sudden it was easier to go to school in the morning.
She got herself up,
got dressed me to snap,
packed her bag,
so proud,
said goodbye to mom at the door.
And for me it was like,
oh,
this is really my job.
You know,
I thought my job is to make you completely safe and to make sure that you
succeed.
But really my job is to teach you how to do things and then let go.
So the German method is to prepare their kids instead of trying to keep them
100% safe,
but to prepare them to manage risks themselves.
Because if we really admitted to ourselves,
there is no way that we can make the world a hundred percent safe for our kids.
It's just not the nature of the world.
The best thing that we can do for them is give them the skills they need to
manage risk on their own.
And one way Germans do this from an early age.
It's your playgrounds.
Oh,
here we go.
And not this playground.
This playground isn't a typical American playground.
Looks familiar.
I could probably find this in any city.
In America,
it's plastic,
it's short.
The slides are plastic,
so they're not very fast.
There is not a whole lot of risk to be had here except for maybe a three year
old or a four year old after that.
It's not even very interesting.
This is a more typical German playground.
And I say typical,
but I have never seen one German playground that was exactly the same as
another,
which you can't say about American playgrounds unfortunately.
But some of the typical elements they have are tall towers and they're much
taller than ours and they have different ways of getting to those towers that
are sometimes a little dangerous.
So if you've,
here's an example that's my daughter up there and you can see from the height
that it's at least twice as tall as she is and she's on a log with just rope to
hang on.
So there's a lot of chance to fall there.
So he's learning right there how to manage some risks.
And not only are they more dangerous or more risky,
they're more fun.
I mean,
what's more fun?
This or this?
Oh,
this one's actually in Bavaria.
Friend sent it to me and that kid is up kind of high.
Uh,
just this is more of a side view of it up.
These climbing rope triangles,
triangles are fairly common.
And if you see at the end that tail,
this whole thing is sort of like a snake.
That tail is a slide,
so the reward for climbing up there as you get to go down that really fun slide,
which might be a little scary now,
I was lucky enough that in our neighborhood we had something called the
Glockenspiel plots and that's the can right there.
Now this dragon has since been torn down and then they built another one,
but it is not only high,
it has scary look to it.
It's got this big red teeth and the kids can actually climb up into those teeth.
You can also hang out in this bullet right here and there are two enormous
slides that go down the side metal,
so they're fast.
My daughter was terrified of this thing.
She would not go near it.
Of course she was really small.
That was her when we first arrived in Berlin.
And this is the area in front of the Dragon,
which has some swings and some other things that you can climb.
And for years she would only play around the dragon the most she would do with
it when we go up the back and down and up and down.
And that was it.
So flash forward two years,
I've got a new baby boy now,
and I'm watching him a lot more than I'm watching her.
And I hear Mama,
Mama,
and I'm like,
Ugh,
she's hurt herself.
I was watching your,
oh my gosh.
Then I look up and she's in the Keith and then she comes down the slide and when
she stands on,
you can just see it.
You know,
she had conquered her fear.
I didn't make her do it all by herself.
And I think that's really important step for a child to take,
even when they're five,
is to face something that they're afraid of and to overcome it themselves and in
their own way.
And she was working up to that point,
I think for a long time.
Um,
and I'm a little afraid that American kids don't get a chance to conquer dragon
very much anymore,
at least outside of a video game.
Uh,
this picture is,
was taken actually several years after that because you'll see there's another
little face up there and that's her brother.
So I guess if you have a,
for older sister,
he get pushed to do things a little bit faster.
Um,
but another really important way that Germans prepare their kids is through,
uh,
using dangerous implements them that we normally don't.
And there's none that is more stark of an example than fire.
What are we taught about fire when we're kids don't play with it.
Don't play with matches.
You ever seen a lighter who told an adult that is not for kids?
That's not the prevailing wisdom in Germany.
And in fact,
my daughter came home from first grade one day and she said,
mom,
I'd like to light some candles because she had learned how to like matches in
school.
And that was quite shocking for me.
But she had the note for,
from her teacher.
And the idea behind this is that Germans think it's safer to teach a kid how do
you,
something that's potentially dangerous than to prohibit it.
Because when you prohibit,
and there's a great amount of children,
especially when it comes to fire,
who will try it in secret and of course in secret is dangerous because it's
secret and because they have no capability in it,
you actually have to know how to hold a match.
A lot of young kids,
we'll hold it like this and the fire burns their fingers and then they drop it.
Then maybe something catches on fire,
right?
And their first thought if it's prohibited is I'm going to get in trouble and
then they run or they hide.
And that's how a lot of child started fires happen.
Now there is a man,
uh,
in kind,
Karl von who is a pioneer in this area and he teaches kids who are even younger
than seven,
how to light matches and candles and not only how to light matches and candles,
but how to make bonfires,
oh no kind carve on.
He's kind of an interesting character because he used to be a fire artist and he
wants burned the Berlin Wall and the 1980s he has since got a second career as a
fire safety instructor.
And his idea of fires safety is to teach very young kids.
He just four or five and six.
This is a kito which is like a daycare center.
How to deal with fire.
Yeah.
What I love about this video is so much is not only do you see these small kids
making fire,
but you see the sawing things using,
going to ax,
um,
cutting food and cooking it.
And I think it really challenges our notion of that kids are incapable and that
they need everything done for them.
And with a little instruction.
They seem to manage quite well.
No.
Um,
these kind of workshops are not everywhere in Germany.
They're more common in Berlin and Brandon Bird.
But before you think Kinda kinda carve on is a completely crazy man.
He has the backing of insurance agencies,
child safety organizations,
and the Berlin fire bow.
Uh,
so do you fire department.
And when I think back to when I saw a firefighter come to my elementary school,
they stood in the front of the classroom and they told me not to play with
matches and how to stop,
drop and roll,
which are all good things,
but never did I make a fire with a fire firearm,
which might be quite a quite an experience.
So the German way of dealing with fires,
almost the complete opposite of ours.
However,
I have found no evidence that child's started fires or have any greater number
in Germany than they are here where we have a lot of prohibition.
So that begs the question then,
if we're prohibiting it and it's not working,
then why are we doing it?
And what is,
what is the lost through that prohibition?
And I think if you saw those kids in that video,
they were incredibly engaged,
right?
Kids are very fascinated with fire and some people even think we're
evolutionally wired,
be fascinated by fire,
cause needs to depend upon it for so long.
But this is also an opportunity for learning,
really intense learning for them.
And that's another subject that we are very concerned about.
Raid.
We all want to know what makes children succeed.
Oh,
here in the U s we have pushed down a lot of,
um,
conceptual learning into kindergarten and preschool and we do worksheets and
flashcards with kids.
In fact,
Americans are famous for trying to Kush learning earlier and earlier this
psychologist Sean pujay once called it the American question back in the 1970s.
And that question was,
can we do it faster?
How can we do it earlier?
And he would answer that question,
why do you want you to do that earlier?
And I have to say,
I'm,
uh,
back in the US,
before we left Germany,
I had this brilliant little daughter who could speak at a really early age and I
thought she said,
genius,
I got to help her.
And I started to teach her how to spell it,
taught her to spell her name while we were swinging and she had your back and
forth and she'd say,
s o,
p.
H hey,
so fair.
And I said,
wow,
that's great.
I'll try something else.
Okay,
so painless,
no money.
And she was saying s,
O,
p,
h,
I,
Hey.
So we may be able to get young kids to repeat back to us a lot of things
including math facts,
um,
and you may even be able to get them to read,
which by the way,
has very little evidence that it gives them an advantage later on.
In fact,
there was a study that showed compared earlier leaders and you know,
four or five with later readers,
more than traditional seven or eight.
By the time both sets got to be 11,
the late readers had caught up.
So again,
it doesn't give them an advantage.
Why are we doing it?
And more importantly,
what are they missing while we are trying to cram reading and math at an early,
early age.
And I would argue that they're missing play.
Play is so essential.
All mammals do it,
including us.
And it's kind of the primary way that we learn.
Um,
and kindergarten,
which was invented in Germany,
it at least there,
um,
for declared liberal had the idea that child learning would take place in a kind
of Eden,
thus the gosh in kindergarten.
Um,
and that play was essential and they've had some changes in kindergarten,
but they are back to that model and all they do in preschool and kindergarten is
play.
And when the ambitious American and me got nervous about that,
they would tell me we leave.
They are learning,
they're learning social skills,
they're learning how to be creative,
how to be leaders,
how to have self control.
And a lot of like kindergarten therapy practice,
what's called this situation on or what used to be known here as the
observational approach and features what stuff back and watch what was going on
with the kids.
And this was one example.
Every year in the golf at our teacher,
they would have a lot of chestnuts come down from the trees and the kids love
them.
It would cram their pockets full of them,
take them home,
take them in the inside rooms rather than fight it.
I said,
God,
get all of them that you can and they bring them in to play with them.
Now I'm sure there's some math skills going on here,
but they're not very formal.
Um,
the other kinds of things that they would do is they would do projects with the
kids but only projects the kids chose themselves.
So they would have a little meeting and they'd say,
okay,
what should I next project?
He and kids would throw out ideas and they vote,
vote on them,
how democratic.
Right.
And then they have the kids throw out all the questions they have about that
particular idea.
Like for instance,
they did a body project one year and so people wanted to know,
kids wanted to know what,
how do the IC,
how did the ears hear the heartbeats?
Um,
what's nice skeleton look like?
And so after that,
for over a period of weeks,
they would investigate it.
They'd get books,
they'd watched videos,
they bring in an expert,
like a doctor or going on a field trip to the museum.
And through that process you're learning how to engage their here acidy and
they're alert,
they're really learning how to learn it.
And this whole emphasis on play and self directed learning goes on through
elementary school.
So like so third or fourth grade.
And if that worries,
you consider that German teenagers,
by the time they're 15,
do much better on the international piece of tests than Americans.
That's math,
science and reading.
So maybe our emphasis on academics so early might be misplaced and that maybe
the kids need more of a foundation of this kind of exploration.
Oh,
the last method of preparation I just wanted to touch on briefly is information.
Germans are much more open with difficult topics with their kids than we are.
And these are things like sex,
religion,
that all of which my daughter had projects on in school by the time of third
grade.
And of course for Germany,
the darker parts in history is a huge topic.
But just to give you one example,
um,
for sex education in Germany,
it's mandatory.
You cannot opt your child out of it for any reason.
Not even religion,
because they believe that the kids have a right to know how their body works,
which I don't know how you take that,
but when I looked at the statistics and the end teenagers in Germany are no more
sexually active than American teenagers.
In fact that statistics are almost identical.
The big difference,
however,
are another very important statistics.
Germans have a much lower rate of teen pregnancy.
I'm much slower rate of teen abortion and a much lower rate of HIV incidents.
So no matter what my morality is around sex and my kids having it at a certain
point and information is powerful and it has a power to help them protect
themselves.
Okay,
so then the big question,
how do we do any of us here?
We have a very different culture,
right?
Um,
and I,
I have to admit there are some things that happened in German society that our
society based and making changes in our school system or our preschool system or
even getting a more exciting playground on the street would retake a lot of
effort,
my group of people,
right?
But there are several things that we can do as parents and as citizens.
Um,
and the,
one of the first ones is what we talked about in the beginning.
Letting your kids learn to navigate their own world.
A child of,
you know,
seven,
eight or nine is very capable of taking themselves to a place,
especially one that they go too often,
like a friend's house,
the school or the playground.
And it makes you nervous.
Try it out the Durban way,
go with them.
A lot of times she's some traffic.
Talk to them about strangers,
possibly approaching them though you should emphasize it doesn't happen very
often and if it still makes you nervous,
find them a buddy because two kids walking down the street feels a lot safer
than a wine.
And it's also helps their siblings involved.
I think,
um,
another thing that we can do as parents,
uh,
it's to make time in every day at the kids to get to decide what to do with it.
And because we have a longer school day now and homework and then
extracurricular activities,
some kids can go from,
you know,
first thing in the morning,
the evening,
never being able to decide what they want to do.
So for us,
you know,
when,
when I do this with my kids,
that usually means tying and it's very important for them.
I think to play every day as it is to get outside,
which was also a German value that said something that's too hard to do either
do,
it does require a push a little bit.
Um,
and another idea is to give them some life tasks.
Even at a young age.
My daughter does her own laundry,
which means I put a band in her roof,
she puts,
she fills it.
Well that's all she does the laundry and has clean clothes.
I really liked this one because it has very natural consequences.
I don't have to Nag and she doesn't do her laundry,
she doesn't have clean clothes.
And for a while she didn't care.
But now she really,
really does.
And it gets done.
And other things like are waking yourself up in the morning.
Uh,
cooking also had very natural consequences and they tend to be very engaged,
especially if you couch it as teaching you how to take care of yourself.
It's not necessarily a chore.
And it was a bit of a step towards independence.
And if we teach our kids these,
these smaller things now at this age they go get to have a growing sense of
capability and as they get older we can give them more and more responsibility
so that it's not such a shock when they become 18.
I don't know about you,
but I did know some people in college who had never done laundry would never
made a pot of rice and that's they're missing out a lot.
They have to catch up really fast.
Um,
and last but not least because the,
the idea I brought up here about being more open with their kids about difficult
topics,
they can handle it.
When I want to tell you what a short story about world war two in Germany,
you can't avoid the topic of World War Two and the Holocaust if you live in
Berlin,
especially because it's everywhere.
Your kids are going to ask you.
But I'll see these little gold sparkles Stein in the street,
but a memorialize people who are taking off the dye and concentration counts.
And whenever I asked my German friends,
the adults about World War II,
they would tell me,
I cannot remember a time when I didn't know what my country had done.
And that really affected me because if they couldn't remember when they didn't
know,
they must've been five,
maybe six when they learned about the one of the biggest crimes in modern
history that their old culture had done.
That's a really heavy issue.
And those kids were about as old as those kids you saw making the fire and using
the act.
So I think our kids are more capable than we realize or that we give them credit
for.
They're more capable of doing,
handling physical freedom and handling tough intellectual and emotional
subjects.
And I think if that's the idea,
I'd like to end the presentation with your,
I think if we as parents can get a handle on our fears like the Germans to and
step back and give her kids the space they need and they can grow up to be
independent Self Hawaiian adults.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
hi.
Hi.
Do you have any advice for parents who would like to give their kids more
freedom but are concerned about things like the kids getting taken by CPS has
happened to that couple in Maryland,
right?
Absolutely.
I mean we do have that problem.
Um,
Germans have that sense of community in that sense that if their kid gets in
trouble that people will help them.
And here we,
we've come to a,
a part in society where people will tend to call the police on you.
The best advice I can give you is to try to know your community and talk to your
community.
Uh,
that means talking to your neighbors and the fellow parents and let them know
what you're doing.
You know,
I'm going to,
my kid really would like to try walking to school.
I'm going to let them do it tomorrow.
And you can get them in on it through busy body and be like,
could you look out your window,
make sure they're okay.
You know,
I think if we start to draw people in to be proactively helpful instead of
negative and perhaps we can start to build that here.
Okay.
How did you get your daughter to start caring about not wearing dirty?
It was actually pretty natural.
You know,
there was a little bit of rebellion,
I don't care for a bit.
And then you know,
her favorite shirt wasn't washed and it just kind of happened.
Yeah.
So I've actually been thinking about a lot of positions for a long time.
I have a three and a half year old and I've been trying to introduce her to,
uh,
to take is that I as an overprotected kid wasn't able to do until much later,
but I think too much.
You can.
Um,
what I'm,
what I've been trying to figure out is like kind of have what ages did you,
what NDAs and feels like a lot of the resources,
especially on the Internet
in America for,
for determining,
uh,
when is reasonable safe time ways that five or six require,
um,
yeah.
And
like you,
can you recommend any resources for figuring out how much earlier than sort of
the American,
uh,
very conservative norms,
different things he moved?
Well,
I,
I'm really reluctant to say that any specific age is good for a specific task.
It's really important to see when your kid is ready for it.
And often they'll tell you,
you can,
you can suggest some things and they'll be like,
ah,
no way.
And I don't recommend forcing a kid who's reluctant,
you know,
like if you wanted to start with,
cutting up potatoes together and they don't want to touch the knife,
I would wait.
They'll come back and I'll tell you a short story about my son in the first time
he wanted to walk to school,
he was six and we were in America and um,
he actually wanted to walk home.
I had driven that day and he had no interest in and get in the car.
And that first time he ran in the hallway and he was scared.
He didn't really tell me he was scared,
but you know,
I kind of knew.
And then he didn't ask again for two or three weeks.
Then when he did it the second time,
that's when it clicked for him.
And today he walks all the time.
So I,
you know,
I would think suggesting some things to your kids and see if they're into it and
then if they go for it,
yeah.
But if they don't,
you know,
back off,
um,
walking to school and the Germans do it at about seven and eight,
the thins do it at four and five,
you know,
so it's,
it's kind of a cultural thing as well.
Do you have any thoughts,
observations,
and how Germans teach responsibility?
So for example,
you told them or you give an example of kindergarten and just play all day,
but did they get taught like cleaning up?
It's not a very natural consequence,
unlike dirty clothes.
So I'm just wondering what their thoughts are.
Observations.
Sure.
The Francis,
it was fairly free form.
The kindergarten went to head very few walls that the kids didn't make
themselves.
Um,
so they actually would sit the kids around and go,
what should be the rules for our keynote?
And one kid will say,
don't cry lumber furniture.
And she said,
why don't you do that?
Just like,
I don't want your dirty feet on it or don't,
you know,
don't hit other kids.
And that's a really natural one.
Why?
Because it hurts.
The second answer is always the most powerful.
Other kids won't want to play with you.
So they learn some responsibility just through the interaction with each other.
Now if you're thinking our parental interactions with them,
all of this responsibility is for sendable,
right?
This freedom.
So if they are being allowed to walk to school and instead,
uh,
on the way home they stop at a friend's house and you say,
okay,
maybe we need to take a break from it for awhile.
And I think kids in that sense,
they,
they get a little bit of a freedom and then the accountability for it so that
when they're older and they're not just going out there and going crazy,
the most amount of [inaudible] as for food,
if I left him,
but what the need is,
like if I have vegetables and fruits on a speaker and he said and done,
and then later in the evening ask for something else.
Yeah,
it's like that.
So I don't know how to balance that.
Giving you come,
did you give such control responsibility to finish up?
Food is a hard one,
but I've heard that if you think about the food you hate most in life,
like for me,
I'm really not a big fan of Brussel sprouts.
Not for any particular reason,
but you're first because I remember being forced teeth on and they have that
connotation on it forever.
Um,
so I would urge you not to force them to eat anything.
I'm always a big fan of continuing to offer.
You know,
I put it,
you only put out on the table what you want him to eat,
but then it gets to choose from that.
And of course the suites are only for treats and not for all the time.
Um,
the Germans do this a little bit just through the way they do school lunches.
Nobody brings their own lunch.
So they have two choices,
usually a vegetarian and a non vegetarian.
And if you don't like it,
you go hungry.
So kids tend to eat if they're hungry.
Oh,
thank you for the,
Thomas is actually a nice,
um,
uh,
my question is,
so if you look at,
sure,
I'm here in the US.
Right.
So,
um,
just for example,
there was a movie you sent you called kidnap a Halle Berry.
Yeah.
Basically he's had,
it wasn't important enough for taking their eyes off for k per second and the
kid got cannot.
And then like my foot touch,
try dropping and all that stuff.
Um,
com.
My question is,
so if I,
if I see him will be like that I'm miss reluctance to let my kid walk to school
or I don't even play on the playground unsupervised for a second.
Right.
So how do you reconcile,
um,
but an environment like that?
Because I,
I'm assuming like in Germany,
they have a lot more control over the media.
Uh,
or he's,
that's the perception that I have been here.
Um,
but they can prevent things like stop,
like movies,
like this truck coming out and say,
Hey,
I know you've be like,
don't,
don't throw things.
Like they're not going to let them know,
rejected gets box on their own.
So how do we consult?
I see it is a different immediate environment.
I don't know that they control it so much.
Um,
but there would not be as much interest in that kind of movies.
We like to scare ourselves a lot here.
What I really wish would happen in Armenia is that whatever they tell us,
one of the real stories of a kid being kidnapped,
but they put it in context.
And as a formal journalist,
I wish we could require this because you're always supposed to put things in
context.
A little more than a hundred kids get kidnapped by strangers every year.
Absolutely.
Every story is horrific,
right?
It's everybody's parents nightmare.
We have 77 million kids in this country.
Something happened to a hundred kids is an aberration,
not a thing that happens every day.
And if we knew that,
if we keep thinking about that,
um,
I think we might change our behavior.
And one other short story,
if I may,
um,
the farmer,
a common scenario of a kid being sexually abused is by someone they know.
And it's usually a man.
And that man wants to have a relationship with your child.
Now the child that has been very constrained and told to a bay adults and
respect their elders all the time,
it's much easier prey to a person like that than a kid who has been raised to be
independent,
is able to say no to adults.
So there's a really strong argument right there for making your kid more
independent,
actually protects them.
Okay.
I come from a different perspective.
Uh,
and then,
um,
so as you can see,
I'm from Germany,
I'm going move to here.
Um,
it's a splits us dummy here does not wear the Nike if you have kids.
Have these values propagated.
Yeah.
So how do you four old on an enzyme?
Well,
how do you propose up to the school system and this kind of educational waiting
works together?
Because for all kids it's
interesting.
So off things like as a pledge of allegiance,
I'm elementary school.
This was pretty scary for my prospector.
Uh,
uh,
that is this bad.
Are you on a secondary approach?
Is like being on time,
uh,
having all your work done.
And uh,
well I'll just comfortable,
I look,
your mentioned is that doesn't look really go wild was the startup education.
No,
I've handled it a couple different ways.
I've had teachers who are receptive it and schools that are,
you know,
I,
I tell them my kids are allowed to go home.
Sometimes I have to write a note because we're very litigious culture.
Say they have my permission to do these things and sometimes I get a little
passive aggressive.
Um,
I have a teacher,
kids do not need to do homework in elementary school.
I will say that there are no grades,
especially till third grade.
Um,
and there's no proof that doing homework help in elementary school.
And I've had arguments with teachers about this and other times I've just said
to my son,
don't do it and you don't have to do the homework.
And if you want to do it and you want to bring me the little piece of paper that
I'm supposed to sign,
which is really interesting.
Transfer of responsibility,
you can't.
And the moment he does that,
he'll probably have passed some bar,
but I don't let them make me control him,
if that makes sense.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
Do you have any theories on how American culture,
yeah,
unfortunately I only have theories.
Um,
a lot of it is the media and those scary stories and scary movies.
I mean we have a show,
I think it's called law and order,
special victims unit where every week a child is in some horrific situation.
And it,
it gives the impression that this happens often.
Um,
I also think that we have very competitive culture and always have.
So we are so worried about our kids' success that we think we need to start them
on that treadmill early.
And it's actually had some very bad results because if you're a kid and you're
working really hard and kindergarten,
first grade so that you can,
you know,
work really hard in middle school and high school so you can get into a good
college and work really hard to get a good job so you can work really hard.
That can be very depressing.
And anxiety producing that,
you know,
where is the moment for enjoyment and the meaning of life really,
as a,
just to constantly compete and be the best and make money or is there something
else there?
That's the value.
And I think if,
if we change our view on that and how we communicate with our kids,
it could help them out a lot.
Okay.
Should we break at this point?
What's in the book?
Um,
some of the stories I told here,
it's a research memoir.
So it's part,
partly my stories and experiences and it's Harley.
I talked a lot of experts on what studies as well.
And I would say it's part manifesto cause I'm trying to make an argument that we
should give our kids more independence.
[inaudible].